et c'est dans ce contexte que la russie
organise des sessions de formation des
forces de déploiement rapide au
kirghizistan proche des pays voisins de
l'afghanistan les précisions c'est avec
notre envoyé spécial sur place antoine
clairement ça y est c'est parti pour
trois jours de manoeuvres militaires ici
dans l'est du kirghizstan les exercices
ont officiellement débuté tôt ce matin
et déjà tout au long de la matinée des
colonnes de blindés avec des tanks mais
aussi des pièces d'artillerie des avions
ou encore des hélicoptères ont visé des
cibles qui se trouve sur les flancs des
montagnes juste derrière moi alors
l'objectif de ces manoeuvres organisées
au sein de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective et bien c'est je
cite la préparation et la conduite
d'opérations visant à neutraliser des
formations illégal armes et d'écouté oui
on applaudit jusqu'à savons que la
situation militaire et politique dans la
zone de responsabilité de l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective reste
difficile
d'oublier
elle est malheureusement moins favorable
dans la région d'asie centrale et se
développe sur fond de prise du pouvoir
par les talibans d'afghanistan pays
frontalier du tadjikistan le terrorisme
international et l'extrémisme religieux
et restent élevés
[Musique]
nous lançons aujourd'hui des manoeuvres
conjointes avec les unités des forces
collectives de déploiement rapide
hrubesch 2021
pendant ces manoeuvres nous allons
travailler de manière pratique sur
l'application des forces et des moyens
du système de sécurité collective dans
le but de protéger des états membres de
l'organisation
sont clairement visés ici les groupes
islamistes en provenance de
l'afghanistan tout proche qui pourrait
bien débordé sur les pays d'asie
centrale et puis des centrales allié de
moscou est le nom donné à ces exercices
est d'ailleurs assez significatif assez
explicite il s'agit des exercices
hrubesch 2021 hrubesch qui veut dire en
français limite frontières